hi there steve kaufman here
and uh today i want to talk about
learning
more than one language at the same time
and the related question of how do you
maintain
the various languages that you have
learned me or someone else if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe so
uh by way of explanation i'm gonna talk
to you a bit about it
what is happening to me right now
um as you know i was doing you may not
know but i was studying greek for three
months but now i'm on my way to
bratislava where there will be a
polyglot conference so bratislava is in
slovakia
after that i'm going to be in ukraine
where obviously they speak ukrainian and
russian then i'm going to be in vienna
and so forth and so on so i have put my
greek aside
i'm not doing any greek right now
and uh
i'm making three presentations in
bratislava
two of them are to an international
group where i will speak english
and one of them is to a group of slovaks
where they had
arranged for a translator
or an interpreter to interpret into
slovak so i said well
i will try to give my talk in slovak or
slovakian
so for the last couple of days
i've been working hard
at
perhaps even more now time goes by so
quickly uh trying to get a handle on uh
the slovak language and in fact i just
finished a conversation with lydia who
is the organizer of the polyglot
conference and we spoke in
slovak and if i get and she's putting
this up on her facebook page and i will
later on give you a link to that video
but so not only now have i put greek
aside
and i'm working on both the czech and
the slovak because i have a lot of
material
for check already in link i spent a lot
of time on
checks some years ago so i'm reviewing
that but then i'm also using this hover
nick this uh
phrase dictionary
trying to get a handle on the
differences between czech and slovak
but
in the back of my mind is that i have to
get on to arabic
and so i
the spirit moved me so i decided to
you know go on the internet and uh get
some information about the arabic
writing system which is the first
obstacle that i have to overcome and i
also downloaded some apps onto my iphone
and ipad where i can review the arabic
script and i spent a bit of time on it
now both looking at these these sheets
and also going through these
so this sort of flashcard gamified a way
of learning the arabic script
and which focuses largely on the sort of
main or the the guess the standard form
of these letters
even though they have a you know they
indicate to you how these change when
they're at the beginning the middle or
the end of a word
i must admit when i see
i can kind of now
take a you know a good stab at guess at
the uh what the sounds are for the main
uh arabic letters but when i see them
written as a word i'm totally lost but
now i'm putting that aside although i'm
taking it with me to look at in the
plane when i get tired of slovak
or check now
my fundamental position is that when you
when i'm focusing on a language like
slovak slovak check more or less you
know very similar
then i have to focus on that language so
i can't do greek
but anything that i am that i do like as
a minor as a break from the slovak say
uh like looking at these arabic letters
it's an investment in the future
the next time i go to pick it up the
arabic letters
i it won't be totally new to me there
will be parts of my brain that have some
sense
of the arabic script
if
after i return from ukraine i decide to
go back and
focus on greek
i'm not going back to nothing i'm going
back to
what i have already invested a fair
amount of time in
and
my experience tells me that
very quickly i will be better than i was
before and this gets back to this
uh theme that i've mentioned before this
interleaving that rather than trying to
block learn something only do this try
and push it into your brain
in fact the way the brain learns is
actually
that it is more effective to learn
something put a lot of effort into
something then leave it aside and then
go back to it now this has various
applications this is for example one
reason why we shouldn't try and block
learn lists of words
um it's why we should vary the content
that we're learning from even within a
particular language
but it also relates to this experience
that i've had when
if i leave a certain language and go off
and do another language for three months
i come to the first language very
quickly i understand better than i ever
did before
uh so uh you know
to me
cracking the code of the arabic script
i must admit it's a little bit daunting
it's you know i read chinese heavy
japanese but
to me i find it difficult because
when the words are all sort of written
together it's very difficult for me to
see where one letter begins and or ends
and the next letter begins however by
chipping away at it gradually by having
a look at it now and maybe a little bit
of a look on the airplane a little bit
like i'm not sort of focused on learning
it i'm just putting in some time and i
know that that investment
is going to eventually when i go to
focus on us
on it is going to enable me to learn it
more quickly so
i guess
to summarize here
i can only focus on one language at a
time because i need a fair amount of
intensity
within that focus of course i try to
vary my activities
listen to difficult stories easier
stories
uh occasionally review the words and
phrases mostly just listen and read
and focus on that language 80 90 of the
time but it's also useful occasionally
to take a break and
the the time that i then spend on
arabic letters or whatever it might be
it's all
noth none of that is going to disappear
it's not like as if you're pouring water
on sand you are starting to create
some
neural connections
related to let's say the arabic script
so that when i go and put more effort
into it it's going to be that much
easier for me so uh
yeah i don't know if that explains um
you know and i should say other people
may may uh have different uh learning
approaches but certainly that is my
approach focus on one dabble in another
but whatever i do in the other dabble is
is worth it because eventually i can go
back to that that's money in the bank as
far as my future learning say of arabic
is concerned so there you have it i hope
that is useful probably a little bit
confusing and contradictory but that's
kind of the situation
that i'm in right now so thank you bye
for now
[Music]
you